a special sunday edition of pftot
everyday weekend style but the nfl never
takes a weekend off especially not with
the season approaching used to be the
nfl got started on labor day weekend now
it's just a few days after the last
unofficial weekend of summer that we'll
have the texans and the chiefs get
together and let's start with the guy
who was once the first overall pick of
the houston texans jadavian clowney
traded last year on labor day weekend to
the seahawks at the time when he was
subject to the franchise tag hadn't
shown up for anything hadn't signed the
tender next thing you know the texans
kick in seven million to get a deal done
he goes to seattle macy's in the
background by the way he goes to seattle
he spends a year there and then he
spends six months almost on the open
market finally agreeing to terms with
the tennessee titans now
it was an interesting saturday night
because even though there was a report
that the deal was done with tennessee
the deal wasn't done with tennessee and
there were efforts made by teams like
the saints and the seahawks to get back
into it and to get clowney to choose
them over tennessee at the end of the
day though he decided to reunite with
mike rabel who was the defensive
coordinator in houston before becoming
the head coach of the tennessee titans
and that relationship presumably went a
long way to get clowney to take an offer
reportedly worth up to 15 million
dollars which means the base value is
less than that we don't know how much
less i had heard last night the talk was
in the range of 12 million dollars what
does he have to do to earn the
difference and the reality is he went
for months
taking the position he would not accept
15 million dollars from anyone with the
season approaching with his agent bus
cook terminated now clowney gets the
deal done to become a member of the
titans and the thing about clowning
don't look at the three and a half sacks
last year look at the film look at the
disruption the f up the play
ability as chris sims calls it although
he'd love to
say something other than f up the play
that's what clowney does he's a
disruptive force other guys get the
tackles the sacks the fumbles the
interceptions it's clowney who can blow
a gaping hole in an offensive line and
destroy a game plan and that's what the
titans will be counting on him to do as
they try to build on
a season that unexpectedly landed them
in the afc championship and maybe with a
guy like clowney if he's healthy maybe
that's the difference if they
get together with the chiefs again in
the post season and remember last year
the titans had a 10-point lead twice in
the first half first they got to get
back to the playoffs clowney will help
them make that happen in a very crowded
and competitive afc south
on saturday a contract we had been
expecting for weeks to sean watson
agreeing to terms with the texans on his
second deal before he was ever in a
position where he was going to take any
hits potentially get injured the injury
risk shifts to the texans with a
four-year extension on top of the two
years that watson had left on his first
round rookie contract from 2017 he gets
paid a lot of money
to compare his contract year by year
through the first four seasons with the
patrick mahomes deal whether it's
signing bonus whether it's money
guaranteed for skill injury and cap at
signing cash flow year one two three
four
all metrics better than the patrick
mahomes deal and after four years
watsonville the contract for two more
seasons
and focusing on as the agents presumably
did doing a deal that compared very
favorably to patrick mahomes there's
some other quarterback contracts you
could look at and say those deals may be
better those quarterbacks got more fully
guaranteed money at signing those
quarterbacks have better cash flow
through one year two year three years
four years one name right off the top of
the head ryan tannahill who has 118
million over four years with his
four-year deal with the titans deshawn
wants to make 110 million over the next
four years which guy would you rather
have over the next four years i'll do
respect to ryan tannehill i doubt that
anyone would say give me tana hill over
watson and yet tannehill over the next
four seasons will make eight million
more than watson and after those four
seasons tannehill will be a free agent
again watson will be under contract for
two more years so
and there are other contracts as well
that
will compare favorably both to watson
and mahomes watson compares favorably to
my homes the reality is the mahomes deal
in the early years is so bad in all due
respect it doesn't take much
to compare favorably to the first few
years of the patrick mahomes contract
but the good news is
watson was able to avoid getting crammed
into that same pigeonhole of a long-term
ultra long-term ridiculous long-term
contract like the deal that my home
signed the chiefs that's going to be a
battle for more quarterbacks to fight as
they try to get their contracts dak
prescott coming up soon others will be
following suit like kyler murray
eventually lamar jackson after this
season when he's eligible for a second
deal it's always better to take a
shorter term contract and have
flexibility
than to to lock yourself in for a dozen
years like patrick mahomes did now i
understand why i did it i get it
it's his right to do it but when we look
across the board at all quarterback
contracts and compare them some are
going to be better than others and the
quarterbacks who commit for 12 years
are going to be in a tough spot to be
able to say i got the best of the
contracts watson's deal
better than mahomes the reality there
are other deals out there better than
both and it makes you wonder how long
until the players realize it and how
long until the market
gets to a point where both watson emma
homes will say i think it's time to redo
those deals because maybe they weren't
as good as they ultimately could have
been
adrian peterson cut abruptly by the
washington football team late last week
quickly finds a new home with the
detroit lions a one-year deal with a
veteran minimum salary worth i'm told up
to 2.3 million based upon yards and
touchdowns and on the surface the lions
have a crowded house in the backfield
they've got carrion johnson second
rounder in 2018 deandre swift second
rounder in 2020 why would they need
adrian peterson well the reality is
johnson has missed 14 games in two
seasons due to injury 14 games nearly
half of his time with the team he hasn't
been able to play and look that's not a
knock on carry on johnson it's a tough
demanding position and adrian peterson
has proven since 2007 far more often
than not he can line up and go deandre
swift had an injury that knocked him out
for a lot of camp and it called into
question his availability for the month
of september so peterson gives them a
guy who can fill in for swift while
swift is getting healthy and also a
hedge against the possibility that
johnson will get injured again
and the end result is you know wherever
adrian peterson goes except new orleans
because it didn't work out there because
they didn't want to use him the way he
wanted to be used he's gotten
opportunities and it feels like he's
going to get opportunities with the
lions and wouldn't be something if he
passes barry sanders on the all-time
rushing list while playing for the
detroit lions oh and by the way he'll
get to play in minnesota again this year
he'll play the vikings twice i'm sure
that he was attracted to that
possibility i'm told two other teams
were interested in adrian peterson but
they wanted to wait
until after week one one of those teams
by the way
plays early in week one and possibly
wears helmets that are
painted red uh other than that i'm not
gonna say anything more about it a
couple of other things to address before
we wrap this up
the buffalo bills working out a new
contract with cornerback trudavius white
remember when he was thinking about
opting out
you'll wonder what was said and done
behind the scenes to get him to commit
to playing and you wonder how much of
the seeds of the contract that was
announced yesterday
were planted back in late july early
august as white was deciding whether or
not to play and look perfectly
legitimate for a player to use the
possibility of opting out as a tool to
get what he deserves white wanted a
second contract he's gotten his second
contract before the season begins and
it's a good deal for him it's a good
deal for the bills he's a great young
defensive back we haven't seen all the
details yet of the tridevious white deal
but the bottom line is he signed it he's
happy the team's happy and now the bills
go forward with a key piece of their
defense in place for years to come
the la chargers have had keenan allen
under contract for multiple years and
they will have him under contract for
multiple years still to come third
contract for keenan allen reportedly
the second highest paid receiver in the
nfl now we know the devil's always in
the details with deals like this we'll
we'll get into the nooks and crannies
when the full numbers become available
and see where keenan allen really fits
in the overall receiver salary hierarchy
but if he truly is the second highest
paid receiver in the nfl there may be
some other receivers who look at that
and say
pay me
possibly with a profanity thrown in on
the front end like they did in the movie
goodfellas but you know the reality is
keenan allen been around for a while not
currently one of the upper echelon
receivers in the nfl and i know he
probably would take exception to that
but look
every receiver worth his salt should
take exception to that the reality is
there can only be so many of the best of
the best receivers in the nfl and most
people would say allen currently isn't
in that group if he's being paid like
he's in that group it's only going to
make other guys want to get paid even
more money than what they're already
making so a busy weekend in the nfl we
may have another edition of pftot by the
time it's all said and done who knows
what's going to happen sunday who knows
what's going to happen monday but what i
do know is thursday night it will be the
texans and the chiefs on nbc and then
just a few days after that the full
slate of week one games
culminating in sunday night with the
cowboys and the rams getting together
for the first game ever at the new
stadium in englewood that's it for now
we'll be talking to you soon check us
out around the clock at
profootballtalk.com
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports